[Musique]
d'à propos de réformes continuons
puisque nous sommes en plein dedans vous
souvenez il ya de cela quelques temps
nous vous avions parlé d'une réforme des
transports urbains avec il était notre
invité sur ce plateau le présidente de
la ratp en effet la ratp souhaite
rouvrir en particulier à paris et ce
sera peut-être le cas aussi dans
d'autres grandes villes soit rouvrir des
lignes de tramway et ce matin michel
chevalet à paris première inauguration
d'une ligne de tramway alors que
d'autres sont en préparation en france
et en particulier en province
oui effectivement il morosi je me trouve
donc le haut un du boulevard garibaldi à
paris vous voyez là il y a la voix
derrière nous il ya la motrice du
tramway
quand on fait aujourd'hui disons
l'inauguration puisque dans quelques
instants devant la presse devant de
nombreuses paul et bien on va couper
symboliquement le ruban tricolore
vous découvrez il est temps que cette
note rédigée à côté de moi monsieur
philippe essig directeur général de la
ratp
donc c'est même un événement important
on remet le tramway en service dans
paris
oui et c'est un événement d'autant plus
important qu'il marque le 127e
anniversaire du premier tramway qu'à
circuler dans paris tiré par des chevaux
voilà donc ce matériel la ré figure
celui qui seront servis cela il s'agit
donc d'un matériel disons classique
oui nous avons voulu mettre en service
cette ligne plus rapidement possible
aussi nous avons repris notre vieux
matériel celui là était construit en
mais vous constatez que là quand même
bonne allure et il marche d'ailleurs
encore très bien
mais entre temps nous avons mis en
fabrication les nouveaux matériels qui
seront mis en circulation sur cette
ligne dans quelques temps alors regardez
bien il mauro masi en avant-première
voyez nos confrères s'ouvre largement à
l'événement la vie du rail va vous
montrer qu'ils ont envoyé ma vie dira
voilà merci la vie du rail vous montre
dont le tramway qui est actuellement en
construction
regardez la revue générale des chemins
de fer pour montrer c'est également une
maquette et voilà vous découvrez ce que
sera ce tramway parisien construit par
alstom
le tramway standards français c'est
exactement monsieur sic le même que
celui de nantes qui circuleront
exactement et puis alors quelques temps
après c'est celui qui circulera
également sur cette ligne n'est pas
commode et croit yards et il est
actuellement en construction à la
rochelle chez alstom là où on construit
des voitures corail et les rames du tgv
voilà donc ce que sera le tramway
français qui circulera donc en france à
nantes peut-être bientôt à grenoble le
strand aux to lose est ici sur cette
ligne bon j'ai à côté de moi on va
revenir donc sur la politique la ratp
c'est vous qui allez dès que le ruban va
être coupé en dire avec ses veaux qui
allait conduire ce premier tramway vous
êtes culture du métro monsieur d'accord
ici le conducteur du métro en mai
et quoi c'est un grand jour pour moi
j'ai vu ça vous changera pas pour damas
est rien oui c'est sûr merci dites moi
monsieur ici qu'elle est quels sont les
autres projets de la ratp en matière de
tramway ça paraît curieux cadre l
autobus le chemin de fer qu'elle
mettront schwenker souterrain maillera
des v10 le tramway et c'est très
important pour nous le travail et nous
avons en ce moment un projet en cours
d'étude
et nous espérons bien qui sera réalisée
rapidement il devrait relier dans un
premier temps bobigny à 5 10 mais nous
espérons ce sera que la première partie
d'un projet plus vaste puisqu'il
pourrait être prolongé à l'ouest jusque
vers nanterre la défense au sud et à
l'est vers fontenay choisi et la prod
bernie ce sera une ligne qui pourrait
être en correspondance avec toutes les
lignes de métro et qui assurera un effet
très structurant sur le développement
des départements limitrophes iso d'un
mot pour nos amis de province qu'il
s'agit de faire une ligne circulaire que
l'air autour de paris en tramway et non
pas en ne tenant pas un problème balade
économie d'énergie économie d'énergie
qualité de la vie moins de bruit et
surtout capacité de transport qualité de
leur exploitation alors un petit coup de
sonnette
on va partir maintenant en direct devant
nos caméras vous aller couper un petit
coup de sonnette now
voilà comme au bon vieux temps d'avoir
les dans le coin on y va à l'essai tirer
tirer que l'on tende pour nos temps
forts
voilà voilà monsieur philippe essig la
marraine marie hélène vous coupez les y
voilà
et sous les applaudissements nos amis
[Applaudissements]
merci michel chevalet pour vous a fait
vivre
l'inauguration de ce nouveau tramway
parisien et de nous avoir donné des
détails sur les plans concernant
l'organisation des transports dans la
région parisienne avec le directeur
général de la ratp
[Musique]